Google Cloud updates learn how we enable
security teams to do more with less in
the latest Chronicle security operations
feature Roundup we highlight some new
capabilities focused on delivering
improved context collaboration and speed
to handle alerts faster and more
effectively check out the newest episode
of people in Planet AI to learn how to
predict the weather and climate risk
with Google cloud and Google Earth
engine workspace users can now harness
the power of generative AI to create
connect and collaborate like never
before check out the blog to learn more
about the first set of AI powered
writing features available for trusted
testers in docs and Gmail get more on
all stories at the links below thanks
for watching